after 10 days of a grueling chess here
in Bucharest Romania we are finally
ready to Crown a champion we are joined
by Michael kodarkovsky the executive
director of the grand Chester and
Augusta druggish the superbet foundation
president and of course our champion
Fabiano Carona Michael I'm going to give
you the first word thank you Christian
it is exciting that our American
Grandmaster first time ever won uh
Armenia classic championship
and uh Fabio was winning many
tournaments in his career and this one
is definitely uh would be one of the
most memorable I believe and I would
like to congratulate him on on this
result and hopefully he will continue
the same path and will be able to win
the whole tour
thank you
Fabi congratulations thank you for
coming here and uh thank you for being
so so strong and full of energy you take
the lead and you continue till the till
the final price we are happy to have you
here and we hope next year we will come
again thank you Michael thank you
Christy for all what you does here
please allow me to offer you this trophy
is uh yours thank you congratulations
and I think we have one more thing
perhaps for a Fabiano Yes actually uh
here are the money
[Laughter]
and I want to say a special thanks for
our executive director of superbet
foundation Christy your Giza is nice to
hear he was taking care about everything
that all goes as should be
congratulations again now I hope for you
and Fabi uh how are you feeling right
now this is a big victory for you you've
never wanted here in Bucharest how are
you feeling yeah it's a great feeling uh
everything went perfectly today I mean
the tournament uh I think went as well
as I could have hoped for there were
some moments that I wish had gone a
little bit better but it was great to be
here I mean the organization was
fantastic it was great to be back in
Bucharest for now the sixth time four
times for the branches tour events and
uh you know always a nice nice city to
visit and I'm glad that I could also win
for the first time here if you could
pinpoint the exact moment where you felt
like you could win this tournament what
would that moment be
uh well about five minutes ago I was
told that that I won the tournament uh
yeah I guess my my game against Yan is
the is the moment that I would probably
pick out but it feels like it was a bit
of an anti-climax because I should have
maybe converted against uh against
alireza to to really feel like I I
deserved the victory fully and I got
just like some fortune in the last two
days at Ali Reza
um lost against I can see on Kristoff
and also today that the whole chasing
pack but uh I survived a difficult game
today against against Richie so overall
it was
um it was good probably you have so many
fans around the world here in Romania as
well you were swarmed uh by kids wanting
your autograph every single time you
were coming out from that playing hole
do you have anything to say to your fans
yeah it's great that you know I've
noticed the last few years a lot more
people are getting into chess I really
feel the energy in a lot of cities not I
mean in Bucharest I really felt it like
there's so many fans here but uh but in
other places as well I feel like there's
a lot of Chess fans
um and you know it's a it's an
international game there's people
watching from all over the world which
is great and
um it's it's a nice feeling that people
really to enjoy watching my chest and
also the chess of my colleagues and uh
that events like this one and other
events in the grand Chester are you know
like giving giving chess back to the
public Fabi once again congratulations
you are the champion of the 2023
Superbad chess classic
guys back to you from here in Bucharest
Romania for the last time back to you in
studio in St Louis thank you Christian
and again our